für mich gibt's heute eher ein
browliting und ein wimpernlifting habe
ich noch nie gemacht also das
wimpernlifting habe ich noch nie gemacht
aber browliting habe ich schon mal
selber probiert noch nie so richtig gut
ich glaube browb bei Mary ist wirklich
die Augenbrauen und wimpernlifting
Adresse in Berlin die haben so gute
Bewertungen und kurz vor Weihnachten
möchte ich mich natürlich richtig schön
machen und damit willkommen zu vlogmas
Tag 19 let's
go
[Musik]
ne genau wir fangen mit dem Wimpern und
wir machen es quasi gleichzeitig bei den
Wimpern machen wir du musst halt
geschlossene Augen haben quasi so die
Augen sind die ganze Zeit zu unten wird
abgeklebt damit die separiert sind die
Wimpern und oben wird auch Pad quasi ich
zeig dir die gleich alle RF geklebt und
hochgeklebt werden dieper aufs Pad okay
und genau und dann kommen die ganzen
Phasen aber das erkl ich dir noch mal
alles ja das sieht voll krass aus oder
also ja ja wenn das macht halt auch voll
viel her weil das öffnet so das Auge und
ist halt sieht bisschen aus wie so eine
wimperverlängerung wenn man gut macht
also du hast auch sehr schöne Wimper
also ich denke bei Dir wird es auch sehr
gut aussehen
ne vorher muss man noch mal traurig
gucken so sehen quasi die Pets aus wo
deine wo du halt die Wimpern hochgeklebt
werden genau das merkst du halt gar
nicht das ist aus Silikon das wird
einfach nur aufs Lied gelegt und die
werden halt drauf geklebt quasi okay und
deine unteren Wimpern werden halt mit
solchen ganz normalen PS separiert alles
klar
okay ja an der Seite s meine sehr lang
und die verhacken sich
ineinander kannst einfach zu machen das
perfekt jetzt müsstest du mir helfen und
zwar die Augen zulassen und einen Finger
aufs Lid legen bei dir hier genau
einfach super und jetzt nur das Auge
aufmachen ohne das aufzumachen super
bisschen
Teamwork so noch mal hochschauen wenn es
geht super muss ich noch
mal wie viele Wimpern ltest du am Tag
unchiedlich weil ich ma auch Kosmetik
dann habe ich immer eine gute
Abwechslung kannst zu machen super dann
habe ich halt eine gute Abwechslung
zwischen Wimpern ich mache auch
Augenbrauen also ich ma das jetzt schon
vier
Jahre und deswegen ist schon so einfach
man kann man hat schon drauf kannst
Finger wieder zu dir legen genau jetzt
kannst du dich entspannen schlafen die
Kunden auch ein ja ziemlich
oft passiert öfters und habt ihr jetzt
vor Weihnachten mehr Buchungen weil alle
sich noch schön machen also Anfang
dezember war es noch relativ ruhig aber
jetzt kurz vor jetzt so ab letzte Woche
ist es richtig voll geworden ja hast du
ja hab schon vorne gesehen bestimmt also
bei uns kann auch spontan vorbeikommen
machen auch medizinische Behandlungen
quasi und ja da kommen auch viele
spontan einfach so
vorbei deswegen darf man sich auch nicht
ver
lassen jetzt kommt quasi
Kleber dann
rechts und die einfach mit zu Meer
kleinen Bürste hochgezogen das ist so
ein Kamm und der nimmt quasi alle mit
und ich kann die dann
so separiert qu sie auseinander dass die
halt gerade liegen und dann habe ich
hier so ein kleinen piieer da klebe ich
noch mal so bisschen besser draf damit
die bisschen besser halten aber beim
wimpernlifting ist halt so toll das ist
halt quasi Chemie wir öffnen quasi die
wimperstruktur also die
katinchüppchen und damit lassen die sich
quasi biegen mit der zweiten mit der
zweiten Phase
lassen schließen wir die Phasern wieder
damit die quasi in der Form bleiben
musst auch gleich merken die Produkte
rie noch ein bisschen wie
derwelle ist ist irgendwie unangenehm
oder so neinin so jetzt mache ich noch
mal im zweiten
Auge dann sag Bescheid
ne du machst das ganz toll
danke zeig mir immer vi meine Hände sind
so leicht sagt stimmt deine Hände sind
wirklich
leicht so so das ist jetzt quasi die
erste Phase riecht bisschen unangenehm
oder also man merkt bisschen riecht
nach
genau bisschen wie eialat
ja und dasselbe mache ich jetzt
eigentlich auch mit den Augenbrauen da
brauche ich die ja nicht hoch zukleben
ja der Geruch ist wirklich irgendwie
ganz ja ganz
eigen was sind die beliebtesten
Behandlungen vor Weihnachten meistens
lifting
tatsächlich ganz viele Unterspritzungen
Lippen meistens oder Botox oder so und
auch Gesichtsbehandlungen aber das so
meistens erst in der Woche so quasi in
der Woche Weihnachten ist oder eine
Woche davor so ich leg jetzt auf die
Augenbrauen einfach so eine kleine
Frischhaltefolie kann man sagen damit es
halt besser
einwirkt
genau so und das lassen wir jetzt auch
die erste Phase hat s quasi geöffnet
dass wir die biegen können und die
zweite schließt sie quasi in diese
Form okay das macht dann die
keratinchoen wieder zu genau
okay
jetzt hier kommt die zweite Schicht
jetzt auch ab ne erste Schicht meine ich
habe ich mich versprochen erste Schicht
we ich war hier schon bei der zweiten
Schicht jetzt kommt hier die zweite
Schicht noch
KR die erste Phas macht eigentlich die
meiste
Arbeit e komisch
oder w überleg Auto zu kommen ganz ehr
ne Parkplatz ist Katastrophe ja glaube
ich nee nee also besser dass ihr mit
Bahn gekommen seid habt ihr euch
Parkplatzsuche gespart auf jeden Fall ja
und
Parkticket gespart das super teuer in
Berlin auch geworden und vor allem hier
4 € glaube ich die Stunde
Alter ja ja das ist schon echt heftig
und du hast den Laden gefunden
durch ich ich habe gegoogelt ich habe
browse
einfach eingegeben und dann kam die Reg
raus und dann kamt ihr raus und dann war
ich so heftig wie viel also ihr seid ja
so gut bewertet ich wollte jetzt auch
eigentlich zu soem Nagelstudio gehen ich
habe das jetzt aber auch abgesagt weil
ich halt die hatten halt glaube ich 3,5
Bewertung auf Vogel und da sind halt so
katastrophale Geschichten gewesen in den
Rezensionen wo ich gedacht habe okay das
L ich weißt du welche so super gehyped
ist dieses Angel nails Angel nails ja
sagt ihr das was nein aber ich ich
brauch so ein geh der ist sehr gehyipt
und den gibt's jetzt mittlerweile
zweimal sogar schon in Berlin geil der
ist soll sehr also ich persönlich war
auch da fähst du die gerade ganz kurz
jetzt mache ich gerade die zweite Phase
ab und hier ist schon Farbe drauf und
hier kommt die Farbe jetzt auch gleich
drauf ach so also wir machen jetzt die
zweite Phase ab genau und färben jetzt
die wimperchen okay ich würde bei dir
die Augenbrauen z.Bp nicht färben ne
weil du hast so ein klar Augenbraun und
dadurch dass die keratinschchen Hal so
offen sind wird die Farbe super schnell
aufgenommen mm und es wird nach wirklich
nicht me einer Minute super dunkel die
augenbra okay und das machen man
wirklich sehr sehr hellen ja ich fühle
mich so richtig als ob ich das als ob
kurz vor Weihnachten wie so eine fette
Überraschung die man kriegt ja aberil du
siehst halt auch gar nichts ne und du
kennst es ja auch nicht eigentlich nee
überhaupt nicht deswegen ach gerade mit
den Wimpern weil ich viele Leute sagen
mir schon immer dass ich voll lange
Wimpern habe ich sehe das halt also ich
glaub we jetzt einfach meine Wimpern
sind jetzt nicht so
deswegen ja bin ich einfach mega
gespannt ja das kann so sein also man
sieht schon also jetzt ist eigentlich
fertig bei den Augenbrauen wenn man
nicht fäht also eigentlich immer ja
kommt jetzt quasi die Pflege drauf also
Keratin Pflege heißt es mhm das
befeuchtet noch mal die Wimpern und
stärkt das noch mal weil wir haben ja
quasi jetzt trotzdem immer noch mit
Chemie gearbeitet und es trocknet halt
aus und deswegen machen man halt immer
diese kreatinpflege immer drüber
deswegen kommt mal Katin
rüberch wer deine augenbra bisschen
glänzen aber das das legt sich Stunden
einzieht das zieht relativ schnell ein
das heiß wenn ich mir jetzt noch ein
gutes augenbrau Gel hole und die so
morgens das wird jetzt perfekt ja gehen
geil das wird jetzt kein Problem mer
sein du bist so ruhig machst so
richtig
R K wenn die das erste mal da sind d
zucken die immer ganz viel was
verständlich ist meine Kunden die öfter
schon da sind die zucken immer also
allgemein die zucken weil das Auge ist
halt schon so eine ftlichere Stelle sind
jetzt auch die hinteren Haare die so
nach unten sind jetzt auch so geformt
ja ich glaub das wird richtig schön
aussehen weil du hast hinten richtig
schöne lange
Wimper mein Gott ich bin kannar
nichtauben auch schon fertig wir müssen
n ein bisschen zupfen okay so reaction B
du bereit
Timo
la das sind doch niemals meine Wimpern
doch doch das ist voll schön und deine
Augenbrauen guck
maltig die
Augenbrauen
richtig ist schon Unterschied zu und das
wird dann jetzt auch morgens wenn ich
aufstehe ja so sehen dann deine Wimpern
aus ohne
Tusche okay ich werde für immer
hierherkmen und wenn jetzt Leute die
mein Video sehen und zu euch kommen
wollen habt ihr wahrscheinlich bis
Weihnachten seid ihr ausgebucht ne ja
Weihnachten ist erstmal voll aber ich
denke mal vielleicht nach Weihnachten
also quasi die Woche kurz vor Silvester
obwohl ich mir da vorstellen kann ich
habe da noch nicht in den Kalender
geguckt aber da gibt's bestimmt auch
noch ein paar Termine weil bei uns kann
man ja auch spontan vorbeikommen
beiwimpern ist halt immer bisschen muss
man immer gucken weil das dauert ja halt
bisschen länger mhm
ich denke mal vor Weihnachten wird's
noch knapp jetzt die
Woche ja gut aber vor Silvester
vielleicht kann man auf jeden Fall denke
ich also
Leute falls ihr Bock habt BR bei Mary
ich verlinke euch noch mal den Laden
unten in der
Videobeschreibung da könnt ihr dann und
wie war doch dein Veronika gerne bei mir
genau dann sagt ihr dass ihr zu Veronika
wollt habt ihr solchewimper
es sieht so schön aus auch die
Augenbrauen die stehen h so gut weil
nicht steht auch nicht hin muss ich
sagen richtig
schön ich sehe so fresh aus kann ich
aufstehen ja und ich schen den Bürstchen
damit du die halt quasi hochbürsten
kannst genau gibt auch noch oh mein Gott
vielen Dank seh gerne super aus boah
diese Wimpern das macht mich fertig C
richtig gut aus es ist ja eigentlich nur
so ein kleiner Unterschied ich kann das
ich vorstellen dass ich jetzt so morgens
aussehe
[Musik]
so